also nur weil er jetzt vier wochen die
leute hinkommen und fußballspielen wird
auf einmal ist das kv system fallen und
alteingesessene kasamis werden sagen
auch menschlich jetzt war ich war ja die
fifa da die kommen aus der schweiz tolle
leute wir revolutionieren wir unsere
ganze gesellschaft unsere ganze kultur
das wird nicht passieren
13 fragen hier kommt die erste sollte
die deutsche nationalmannschaft die wm
in katar boykottieren ja oder nein wenn
ihr sagt ja angesichts der
menschenrechtsverletzungen ist ein
boykott mehr als angebracht dann bitte
auf die grüne seite gehen und wenn ihr
sagt nein ein boykott könnte sogar
eventuell mehr schaden als helfen dann
bitte auf die gelbe seite gehen
[Musik]
vielen dank jetzt wissen wir wo ihr
steht aber wo steht ihr eigentlich in
knapp einem jahr geht sie los die
fußball weltmeisterschaft 2022 in katar
mitten im deutschen winter und die
deutsche nationalelf hat sich ja längst
qualifiziert die frage ist sollte sie
auch teilnehmen denn schon bei der
vergabe vor rund zehn jahren gab es ja
heftige korruptionsvorwürfe und weitere
kritik katar halte sich nicht an
fundamentale menschenrechte also es geht
um die benachteiligung von frauen die
unterdrückung von schwulen und lesben
und auch die moderne sklaverei auf den
wm baustellen grund genug sagen die
einen für einen boykott als klares
zeichen gegen diese
menschenrechtsverletzungen im moment so
einfach ist es nicht sagen die anderen
ein boykott könne eventuell sogar mehr
schaden als helfen bei 310 fragen geht
es ja um den kompromiss es wird heute
spannend zu sehen sein ob diese beiden
parteien aufeinander zugehen können und
wie ein kompromiss überhaupt aussehen
könnte das werden wir am ende der folge
sehen jetzt erstmal die frage an euch
wie würdet ihr euch entscheiden auf die
grüne seite gehen und sagen ein boykott
ist jetzt dringend notwendig oder auf
die gelbe lieber nicht das könnte
eventuell sogar schaden schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare und gegründet
gerne eure meinung ganz kurz zu den
regeln wenn ihr im laufe der folgenden
diskussion der gegenseite zustimmt dann
geht gerne einen schritt auf sie zu auf
dem feld wenn ihr sagt eigentlich finde
ich deine meinung sogar plausibel aber
das was du jetzt gerade erzählt ist
totaler quatsch dann könnt ihr auch
gerne einen schritt zurückgehen mein
ziel ist es am ende der folge möglichst
viele von euch hier in diesem
sogenannten kompromiss feld wieder zu
finden also wir suchen ja eine lösung
und wollen den konflikt nicht noch
weiter verhärten 13 fragen hier kommt
jetzt frage nummer zwei und die geht an
nennen als ehemaliger profi warst du ja
sogar schon mal bei einer
weltmeisterschaft
2010 in südafrika glaube ich möchte gar
nicht so erfolgreich kann man sagen wenn
du jetzt heute nochmal 20 oder anfang 20
wärs und gefragt werden würde ist kommst
du mit nach katar würdest du ja oder
nein sagen kommt drauf an welches wissen
ich habe und welche heizung ich habe mit
der erfahrung der ich jetzt habe würde
ich das nicht tun mit der erfahrung die
ich damals hatte glaube ich würde ich
das tun und deshalb glaube ich auch dass
verantwortlich für die spieler die schon
mehr lebenserfahrung haben auch zu
helfen so eine entscheidung vielleicht
manchmal mitzutragen aber grundsätzlich
finde ich es schwer dass jetzt alle
mannschaften oder auf einem die großen
mannschaften absagen bei gesprächen auch
nur über die menschenrechtsverletzungen
weil es die wm gibt und auch nur deshalb
ist der aktuelle druck auch da ein
boykott würde nicht nur zu nichts führen
sondern er würde schaden wir haben eine
brücke die der sport ist um auch unter
menschen gruppen untereinander
zusammenzukommen und den sportlern sich
zu feiern und das auch als
verbindungselement zu nutzen und diese
brücke sollten wir unbedingt nutzen du
glaubst du boykott wäre eher
kontraproduktiv in sachen menschenrechte
es würde nicht dazu führen dass die
menschenrechte die wir hoffen sich dort
etablieren dass diese tatsächlich auch
realisiert werden ich denke es würde
schaden also nennen sagt die
menschenrechtsverletzungen müssen an die
öffentlichkeit und sie kriegen durch
eine wm auch eine große öffentlichkeit
und ein bankrott wäre eher
kontraproduktiv könnt ihr das
nachvollziehen also ich kann die
argumente absolut nachvollziehen
natürlich mit einem spotlight werden
auch diese themen aufgearbeitet die
ansonsten überhaupt nicht bei unserem
radar erscheinen aber ob die konsequenz
dann wirklich die ist dass wir bessere
menschen rechtsverhältnisse in katar
wirklich haben das bezweifle ich
deswegen bist du auch nicht nach vorne
genau deswegen ich mich nicht bewegt ich
war kurz davor aber dann dachte ich nein
es passt einfach nicht ich persönlich
ich als frau
sehe natürlich auf die wm in katar auch
noch mit besonderen augen frauenrechte
spielen daher neben anderen grundrechten
keine rolle und auch hier lebenden
menschen werden dort ja wie soll ich
sagen mit füßen getreten du bist ja nun
selber leidenschaftlicher fußballfan
aber auch aus durchaus auch aus
persönlichen gründen willst du diese wm
einfach generell ablehnen warum erklärt
ja also ich bin ein fußball fan und ich
bin auch nicht islamfeindlich und hab da
auch keine vorbehalte aber ich habe
tatsächlich schon ein problem damit dass
wir da in einer absoluten monarchie zu
hause sind wo dieser fußball ausgetragen
wird und darüber hinaus eben du hast du
es in der moderation ja auch schon
zusammengefasst die menschen werden fast
klar frauen sind leibeigene ihrer männer
das kann ich einfach nicht mittragen und
möchte es auch nicht mitgehen ich bin
ich bin auch eine frau die in diesem
land eigentlich gar nicht gut leben
könnte und ich könnte auch schon gar
nicht als quer lebens dort wirklich zu
hause sein und ich sehe halt auch keine
beweisführung dass in der vergangenheit
ein großes sportereignis wirklich die
folge hatte dass ich da grundsätzlich
was verändert hat wie geht's euch geht
einen schritt auf sie zu ich meine man
muss ganz klar sagen was du gerade
gesagt hast frau tierlieben nach der wm
würde verließ ja im knast landen
wahrscheinlich also ich lese da vorne zu
viele film zu stimmen das ist klar dass
dort keine frei zivilgesellschaft gibt
keine gewerkschaften es gibt keine
freien wahlen ist es eine erbmonarchie
aber ich finde wir sollten uns jetzt ein
jahr vor der wm bisschen mehr auf die
auf die realität zu bewegen in der
geschichte sport haben nur ganz ganz
wenige brücke etwas gebracht mit einem
autoritären regime wie ein kater muss
man glaube ich diplomatische sprechen
damit man positive effekte bekommt wer
verdient denn an dieser wm geld das sind
große deutsche konzerne die dort eine
straßenbahn bau und die dort viele
trikots verkaufen worden die dort
maschinen herstellen und wenn man dieses
turnier boykottiert da müsste man die
gesamte globalisierte wirtschaft und die
gesamt globalisierten fußball
boykottieren und deswegen ist es leicht
auf katar draufzuhauen aber wir auch als
kritische fußball fans gehören zu einem
fußball systemen in dem menschen zu
schaden kommen also sollte man muss bei
den komplett boykottieren aber es ist
nicht klar da jetzt mal wirklich einer
zu viel also ja kommerzialisierung
fußball moral und ethik wird nicht so
groß geschrieben es geht ums geld
verdienen und so weiter aber bei katar
ist auch alle so was von offensichtlich
dass ein boykott doch irgendwie auch ein
zeichen richtung fifa wäre unter dem
motto ein bisschen und nicht weiter und
es gibt auch grenzen als fußballfan
möchte ich einfach kein eröffnungsspiel
an einem novembertag sehen und eine wm
im winter erleben
und als politischer mensch möchte ich
nicht dass die deutsche
nationalmannschaft beziehungsweise
deutsche spieler teil eines so großen
inszenierten politischen zirkus sind und
ein regime damit
legitimation erteilen durch die
teilnahme an der werden wie weit will
man denn dieses ganze spiel noch treiben
wenn jetzt schon darüber nachgedacht
wird wir machen den wir alle zwei jahre
also es sind ja nicht nur die
menschenrechtssituation in katar die man
irgendwie berücksichtigen muss sondern
auch die kommerzialisierung im fußball
und wo geht das alles hin und wer wird
überhaupt gefragt ich glaube dass das
genau der entscheidende punkt ist ich
glaube die frage des boykotts ist vor
allen dingen
dem fakt geschuldet dass viele
versprechen und viele gesetze die es ja
gibt ja die ist ja unbestritten gibt
dass die aber nicht eingehalten werden
und dass gerade die öffentlichkeit oder
auch die fußball interessierte
öffentlichkeit
frustriert ist und eben immer wieder
sieht haye die leute leiden trotzdem
weiter es gab viele versprechen von der
fifa aber auch von der katarischen
regierung die wurden alle nicht
eingehalten
wir wissen es gibt weitere
menschenrechtsverletzungen
ich glaube dass die boykott diskussionen
druck erhöhen wird und weiter einen
großen fokus auf dieses thema lenkt aber
das soll eine spannende frage ab welchem
grad
menschenrechtsverletzungen ist ein
boykott gerechtfertigt und war nicht
also ich mir hat mir brasilien südafrika
lief auch schon vieles nicht besonders
gut auch in sachen menschenrechte warum
ist dann katar jetzt der punkt wo du zum
beispiel sagt boykott jetzt ich glaube
es geht gar nicht darum dass jetzt leute
sagen dort soll keine wm stattfinden
dort kann meiner meinung nach sehr wohl
eine fußball wm stattfinden aber diese
ganzen begleitumstände die wir in den
letzten elf jahren sehen die führen eben
dazu das auf deutsch gesagt die
fußballfans die schnauze voll haben und
sagen bis hierhin und nicht weiter bis
hierhin und nicht weiter ganz
nachvollziehen sebastian ich kann es zum
teil nachvollziehen ich glaube dass sich
die diskussion eben jetzt an katar so
hochgeschaukelt hat aus ganz vielen
gründen wenn er mir du hast einige davon
angesprochen ich glaube aber dass ein
boykott eben nicht dazu führen würde
dass diese diskussion weiter geführt
wird ich glaube ein boykott ändert
nichts ein boykott von einzelnen ländern
trägt nur dazu bei dass die situation
sich verschärft nicht alles in katar hat
sich verbessert aber es gibt
fortschritte und diese sind vor allem
ausdruck erfolgt und deswegen glaube ich
dass die aufmerksamkeit nur dann
erfolgen kann wenn man das ganze thema
breit anlegt und dazu gehört eben auch
aktivität in katar und präsenz in katar
zu zeigen wir sprechen einmal über die
situation der menschenrechte da bin ich
der meinung dass migration nicht nur in
katar stattfindet sondern migration
quasi nach katar führt aber ja auch
schon in pakistan in bangladesch in
vielen vielen anderen ländern
stattfindet wo die situation für die
menschen so katastrophal ist
wirtschaftlich und gesellschaftlich dass
sie quasi das land verlassen müssen sie
werden auf der reise dahin von oftmals
kriminellen rekrutierungs agenturen
ausgebeutet müssen enorme summen
bezahlen und landen dann in katar wo
sozusagen dann die ausnutzung die
ausbeutung gewisse art und weise weiter
geht und deswegen glaube ich eine
austragung der wm verbunden mit
maßnahmen die vom sport von der politik
von angeles von der internationalen
gemeinschaft diese migrations strukturen
kritisieren in der gesamtheit die macht
glaube ich sind das problem ist nicht
gerade als land das problem ist die fifa
problem ist die institution der fifa die
eben in den letzten jahren bei vielen wm
es eben ja korrupt vergeben hat wo
korruption eine große rolle spielt es
gibt viele menschen in der region die
sich freuen dass diese wm auch mal in
ihrer region stattfindet und nicht nur
in südamerika europa oder asien diese
leute haben eine gewisse berechtigung
auch darum den sollte man zumindest zu
hören und von daher glaube ich sind dass
die dinge über die wir sprechen sollten
jetzt ruby du bist also halt gerade nach
vorne gegangen
bleiben wir doch mal beim letzten punkt
vielleicht nenne ich würde jetzt einfach
den punkt den menschen die in der region
würdest du die fußball-wm madig machen
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wie
die katar qatar alles selber sehen gibt
ja auch nicht so viele gibt glaube ich
nur 200.000 300.000 der rest sind ja
eines gast 1000 jahren geht ja auch
nicht nur das wesen der region es geht
um die region also es geht sozusagen die
arabische welt auch die um die
islamische welt und quasi katar hat eben
aus vielen gründen über die wir schon
gesprochen haben die auch recht
problematisch sind die möglichkeiten so
eine wm ausrichten die halt ägypten
tunesien oder jordanien nicht hat aber
wollte ich nicht unterbrechen schuldiger
ja nee nee das ist ja klar die diva
freuen sich dann wahrscheinlich auch ein
paar leute aber ich meine 200 milliarden
euro kostet dieses ganze projekt glaube
ich und da muss man sie haben ein
bisschen die frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit stellen also bis
2021 wir reden über
ressourcen klimawandel und so weiter und
dann stellt man damit in die wüste das
alles hinführt 200 milliarden euro auf
der basis einer korrupten vergabe in ein
land wo die fußballkultur quasi nicht
existiert damit wir so ein eiertanz
machen damit wir im winter damit dass
auf jeden fall da stattfinden kann im
winter auf dem weihnachtsmarkt die wm
gucken also das ist doch ein bisschen
viel des guten also jetzt sind alle drei
nach hinten gegangen warum zum einen
weil wir katar nicht aus den falschen
gründen kritisieren sollten das winter
argument ist kein argument weil irgendwo
es überall es ist uns mal warm ist mag
alt und ich finde wir sollten auch mehr
auf die argumente und die motivation von
katar schauen katars einen sehr wohl
haben der staat die brauchen unsere
zuneigung eigentlich nicht warum
bekannter die wm weil sie lange und
damit der bedrohung von saudi arabien
standen weil sie angst vor einem krieg
haben vor anderen versionen deswegen
nutzen wir die nähe zu westlichen
partner in wissenschaft fußball politik
eben auch als sicherheitspolitik die wir
auf die frage ob wieder an mitmachen
sollen dennoch die un hat mit mehr als
200 mitglieder die viel fahrt noch mehr
mitglieder und die besteht eben nicht
nur aus europäischen demokratien
deutschland skandinavien
wenn ihr keine wm mehr haben wollte in
china in der in der arabischen welt eher
müsst ihr ein argument haben wir die
staaten in nordamerika in lateinamerika
in afrika weil die fans dort zu
motivieren dagegen zu stimmen also wie
ich diese debatte wird in westeuropa
geführt und sie wird wahrscheinlich mal
in spanien geführt sondern nur in
deutschland und in großbritannien das
reicht nicht wenn ihr mir hast du nicht
überzeugt warum nicht ich würde noch mal
ganz gerne schritt zurückgehen wenn wir
uns nochmal die vergabekriterien
anschauen menschenrechte haben damals
überhaupt keine rolle gespielt und für
mich spielt die verantwortung der fifa
eine sehr sehr große rolle natürlich
kann man oder muss man auch katar
kritisieren aber man muss eben an die
strukturen ran man muss schauen warum
spielt geld so eine große rolle und das
ist für mich immer auch eine ganz
entscheidende frage welche verantwortung
trägt die fifa und wird wird die fifa
dieser verantwortung gerecht und aus
meiner sicht absolut nicht vollkommen
klar die die fifa diskussion und
überhaupt der profifußball oder
überhaupt profisport in gänze das ist
sicherlich ein thema aber lasst uns doch
mal versuchen heute ein bisschen
realpolitisch zu bleiben und zu gucken
boykott ja oder nein was machen wir
jetzt hilft das jetzt konkret also wir
reden jetzt über in einem jahr das ist
relativ kurzfristig und wenn jetzt ein
boykottaufruf kommt ist ja die frage
unterstützen oder das unterstützen wir
ihn nicht und hier war das argument mit
eurem boykott mit eurem sage ich jetzt
mal mit euren boykott helft ihr den
menschen und dem thema menschenrechte
eben nicht weiter sondern im gegenteil
ihr torpediert sie vielleicht sogar was
antwortest du ich glaube dass wenn es
einzelne profis gibt die sagen da mache
ich nicht mit ist das meiner meinung
nach das maximale zeichen was wir
erwarten können ich glaube wie gesagt
nicht das große fußball
nation nicht hin fand ich glaube aber
sehr wohl dass profis das was ihr nerven
auch grad gesagt hat mit der erfahrung
die er jetzt hat als erfahrener als
gestandener spieler kann ich mir sehr
wohl vorstellen dass das spieler sagen
wir fahren dort nicht hin und ich glaube
dass das ein sehr sehr wichtiges zeichen
wäre verließ ja wir hatten gerade das
thema gehabt menschenrechte verteidigen
geht mit boykott eventuell schlechter
war das argument von dieser seite du
stimmst dem nicht zu warum nicht also es
ist doch irgendwie plausibel dass man
sagt hey da ist soviel spotlight drauf
jetzt können wir da wirklich die gesamte
weltöffentlichkeit mal drauf setzen und
am ende hilft es den menschen vor ort
vielleicht tatsächlich mehr ich habe
vorher angebracht ist eine absolute
monarchie es ist ja auch ein land das
sich vom göttlichen getragen fühlt die
gesetzgebung ist gott gemacht und staat
ist nie gut gemacht auch ein königreich
ist nicht göttlich also wir haben ja da
schon in wirklichen grundkonflikt den
wir hier austragen müssen für die werte
die wir stehen und natürlich wir hatten
auch eine wm in russland also wir wissen
alle wie vergaben funktionieren die
folgen nicht nur völkerverständigung das
ist ja total naiv sondern dass ihr das
geht um ein ganz anderes spiel und
um geld genau um sehr viel geld und das
ist doch dass das ganze leid motiv und
von dem bin ich ist eben auch leid und
diese diese systeme werden vor allem von
männern getragen ob in katar oder bei
der fifa und das ist ehrlich gesagt der
punkt wo ich wirklich sagen ich hab die
schnauze voll und sehe der wirklich ich
habe gar keine lust ein ein großes
turnier zu boykottieren junge menschen
von ihrem sportlichen erfolg abzuhalten
aber wie soll dieses rad denn irgendwann
mal gestoppt werden ich habe keine idee
wenn da nicht irgendwann wir kennen alle
neuanfänge erstmal musste irgendwie
grundlegend mal ein stoppschild rein und
wenn es eben ein bot ist der da am ende
helfen kann dass wir eine neue ordnung
finden dann bitte schön jetzt waren die
ganze zeit in der mitte und das stopp
schild hat sich nach hinten getrieben
warum das klingt doch total plausibel ja
das klingt total prosieben ich finde
aber auf der anderen seite wie
haben in unserer menschheit auf ein paar
schöne dinge geschaffen kultur ist eine
davon und vor allem wenn wir auch auf
kultureller ebene
eine basis haben auf der wir uns
austauschen oder der wir als nicht nur
die kataris an sich sondern die wm man
sich wo viele nationen vertreten werden
die besten finden sich dann vor ort und
haben einen wettbewerb der dann von den
fans und den nationen damit auch
getragen gefeiert und erlebt wird das
ist ein wunderschönes ereignis für für
die menschheit ich würde das nicht weg
schaffen weil mir die eine aspekte die
ein aspekt in die sicherlich auch
wichtig sind also wir sollten die weiter
behalten ich glaube
benjamin hat das sehr gut gesagt wir
sollten sehr sehr gezielt mit den
massnahmen umgehend nicht einfach weg
schaffen und dann hoffen dass irgendwas
sich verändert sondern tatsächlich sehr
gezielt da wo es nötig ist da auch die
die punkte drauf setzen wir haben schon
darüber gesprochen in katar die
menschenrechtsverletzung sollten wir
nicht klein machen ganz im gegenteil wir
sollten sie groß machen und auch groß
halten weil es sind menschen gestorben
amnesty hat jetzt auch vor paar tagen
darüber berichtet dass genau diese
politischen maßnahmen über die du
sprichst nicht implementiert wurden er
zumindest gab es politische maßnahmen
und in diesem fall müssen wir natürlich
auch zur kenntnis nehmen der kam nicht
durch eine soziale revolution wo die
leute das eingefordert haben sondern in
diesem fall müssen wir leider annehmen
es gab erst mal den politischen wandel
und hoffentlich kommen dann auch der
soziale wandel gleichzeitig können wir
auch den sozialen wandel für
menschenrechte darin etablieren indem
wir den kontakt und auch den respekt
füreinander aufbauen und da der dich
nicht über füreinander von politik zur
politik und bedingt sondern auch
zwischenmenschlich und da sehe ich es
als falschen punkt jetzt das erste mal
dass im nahen osten eine wm
ausgetragen wird genau ist denn zu
diesem zeitpunkt zu machen und da gebe
ich euch auch völlig schlecht fußball
das ist eine ganz andere debatte fußball
verliert
verliert den anker und es geht nur noch
um geld newcastle wurde vor kurzem auf
werken gebaut ich bin da nicht das für
ganz im gegenteil und trotzdem ist ruby
nach levins aussah so leicht nach vorne
gegangen er hat nerven hat ja auch
argumentiert es hilft im zweifel den
menschenrechtslage sogar mehr wenn da
wirklich was passiert und endlich mal
dieses zarte pflänzchen so ein bisschen
gegossen wird wichtig richtig verstanden
habe wie erklärst du dir das also ich
habe nach vorne gegangen sei nervend
sagte man musste ja gezielt gucken was
man da macht ich glaube auch dass es ist
illusorisch ist das ganze verbände jetzt
das boykottieren werden aber die
berliner aus sagte ein einzelner kann
schon sehr viel bewegen wenn ein großer
spieler oder ein spieler einer großen
nation sagt ich gehe da nicht hin und er
hat vielleicht einen schlauen berater
der sagt pass mal auf gehen die ist
dieses und jenes
medienformat und dann thematisieren wir
das alles mal warum gehst oder nicht in
unser ziel das über deine über seine
biografie und über deine entscheidungen
und du setzt jetzt quasi durch deine
entscheidung zu boykottieren eines
einzelnen hat den spot line of qatar
dann könnte das glaube ich sehr viel
bewegen und ganz andere spotlight setzen
als wenn man die normalität bedient und
alles so macht wie fifa und qatar sich
das so vorgestellt haben und wie gesagt
das ist noch mal eine sehr künstliche
veranstaltung das hat man auch in
brasilien gesehen das hat man in
südafrika gesehen dass diese fifa zonen
entstehen dass da etwas hingestellt wird
für vier wochen und dann sind wir wieder
weg und
wir hinterlassen brachland also dadurch
wird sich nichts ändern und was ich auch
noch sagen wollte man darf glaube ich
nicht so naiv sein welchen bekehren
charakter so eine fußball-wm haben
kann also nur weil jetzt vier wochen die
leute hinkommen und fußballspielen
werden jetzt wird auf einmal jetzt nicht
das kv system feilen und alteingesessene
kataris werden sagen auch menschlich ist
jetzt war ich war ja die fifa da die
kommen aus der schweiz tolle leute wir
revolutionieren mal unsere ganze unsere
ganze gesellschaft unsere ganze kultur
das wird nicht passieren die
menschenrechtsaktivisten von amnesty
international und human rights watch
sagen mag ja alles sein dass du dass du
recht hast aber trotzdem sind wir gegen
einen boykott weil wir glauben dass
dieses zarte pflänzchen so besser
gegossen werden kann was antwortest du
den ich weiß dass das illusorisch ist
unabhängig davon also wenn du es gibt
sicher in der ganzen sache ziemlich
weckt also vom dfb ist glaube ich so
ziemlich gar nichts zu erwarten
dementsprechend wird das nicht passieren
in einer idealen welt wenn jetzt ein
verband wie der dfb sagt wir
boykottieren das und machen uns mal
gedanken mit denen weltklasse spielern
die wir haben die weltweit bekannt sind
die den fokus auf qatar lenken ich
glaube dann würde man sehr viel mehr
öffentlichkeit herstellen als ist
überhaupt jemals möglich wäre wenn du da
hinfährt und spielst du sebastian ist
die ganze zeit hin und her laufen habe
ich gesehen du warst mein in der mitte
dann ist wieder zurückgelaufen also ich
bin vor allem deswegen zurückgegangen
weil das bei das religiöse argument kam
darauf möchte ich jetzt aber weniger
eingehen sondern ich möchte nur kurz was
zum kampfsystem sagen du hast natürlich
grundsätzlich recht ist ist ein system
was es schon seit generationen nicht nur
in den golfstaaten sondern in der
gesamten arabischen welt gibt ist gut er
auf gewohnheitsrecht als auf
qualifizierten recht das ist auch das
problem dass zum beispiel im häuslichen
bereich die regelungen einfach nicht
verschärft werden können meistens weil
das tatsächlich nicht der autorität des
staates oftmals obliegt sondern
demjenigen der halt im häuslichen
bereich auch das sagen hat und es ist
meistens dann der hausbesitzer und es
ist ein sehr komplexes konstrukt was
eben auch gesellschaftlich teilweise
tief verankert ist und da sprechen wir
über rassismus da sprechen wir über
wirklich ungleich verhältnisse in den
jeweiligen fall in den jeweiligen
gesellschaften und das ist ein
riesenproblem politisch kann man das
angehen aber es ist eben nicht
ausreichend und deswegen gibt es
natürlich große gravierende probleme in
der umsetzung ich glaube aber dennoch
dass der politische die politischen
reformen oder zumindest die die
gesetzesänderungen dazu geführt haben
aufgrund des drucks dass man nicht nur
ein kater sondern in der gesamten region
ganz anders über kafka und überbot
schafft und über migration sprechen
kennt sich in der region relativ gut aus
auch aus beruflichen gründen durch lässt
sich auch sehr gut aus denn du warst ja
sehr oft da kannst du das nicht
nachvollziehen was er sagt das zarte
pflänzchen was da gerade in teilen am
wachsen ist auch in den letzten zehn
jahren durch den öffentlichen druck ist
das nicht nachvollziehbar für die das
ist auf der einen seite nachvollziehbar
aber auf der anderen seite muss man ja
aber das geht nicht nach vorne joe so
nachvollziehbar ist es dann auch nicht
so nachvollziehbar ist es nicht und ich
werde ich auch sagen warum es für mich
nicht so nachvollziehbar ist nämlich
weil hinter dieser öffnung aus meiner
sicht eine ganz klare strategie steht
nämlich die strategie dass die
ressourcen in diesen ländern irgendwann
mal zu ende gehen werden und die
königshäuser ganz klar wissen wir müssen
uns dem westen öffnen da dort sind
unsere dort sind neue
investitionsmöglichkeiten aber was ist
mit der pressefreiheit was ist mit der
meinungsfreiheit was ist mit der
freiheit für homosexuelle da tun sie
sich sehr sehr schwer sobald es um das
finanzielle geht da sind sie sofort
vorne mit dabei aber wenn wir zum
beispiel an den fall von jamal karsli
denken oder andere beispiele
dort verharren sie meiner meinung nach
in ihren traditionen und wollen sich
eben nicht nicht öffnen jetzt könnt ihr
natürlich jetzt könnte man argumentieren
es könnte ja alles viel besser sein aber
verließ ja wäre es vielleicht ohne diese
wm in katar alles viel schlimmer ja klar
wenn wir jetzt hier diese wm nicht
hätten und wir jetzt alle auch heute
nicht darüber sprechen würden dann würde
es diesen spotlight nicht geben ich
glaube das ist nicht von der hand zu
weisen inwieweit das auswirkungen
wirklich vor ort jetzt hat die auch
nachhaltig positiv sind für die menschen
weil das geht doch immer auch mal die
ohnmächtigen zu ermächtigen und ich habe
da halt einfach da sehe ich irgendwie
die löhner die im monat 250 euro
bekommen oder die oft auch nicht
bekommen hashtag lohn diebstahl der ja
da auch einfach gang und gäbe ist weil
es da keine handhabe gibt weil die
gesetze nicht angewandt werden und im
gegensatz dazu diese milliarden gelder
die die da hat die da ausgegeben werden
stadien werden gebaut wo man gar nicht
weiß ja nachhaltig sind die auch nicht
wird 40 grad auf 25 runtergedreht das
sind alles dinge
die ich einfach unvereinbar finden auch
für die spieler die da hin kommen die
ganzen menschen ich unterstelle denen
gar nichts böses aber das ist doch
einfach pervers dass ich ich kann nicht
anders als menschlich zu argumentieren
ist das ist jetzt schon klar das ist
doch ganz viel applaus damit jeder die
applaudieren in deutschland der danke
steht in westeuropa wenn aus harmonie ja
was ja auch okay das ist jetzt
betrüblich ich bin hier um dich zu
überzeugen ist keine verantwortung du
musst dich niemandem rechtfertigen es
ist
klar dass jeder dass das gut findet aber
in katar zum beispiel auch in anderen
regionen der welt haben die eine sehr
ist ein sehr sensibles
sensorium wie wir sie dort beurteilen
zwar in russland aus in brasilien und in
katar führt das sogar dazu dass sich
viele trotz sich noch mehr zurückziehen
weil die sind extrem
ja schockiert darüber seit zehn jahren
wie dort die kritik auf sie einprasselt
es gibt konservative kreise die die
wärme am liebsten zurückgeben würden
also wir verlangen vom fußball etwas was
wir von den großen konzernchefs
anscheinend nicht erwarten die dafür
größere profite machen warum nicht was
kleineres unsere fußballclubs schalke
bayern münchen borussia dortmund niemand
hat ein ernstzunehmendes menschenrechts
konzept niemand schaut auf welche
sponsoren auf welche trainingslager
lassen wir uns ein niemand hat bei einem
dreistelligen millionen etat eine ernst
zu nehmende abteilung die diese themen
angeht und wir hauen auf katar drauf
haben aber bei uns noch nicht mal die
hausaufgaben gemacht und warum nicht was
kleineres warum nicht hinfahren
interesse entgegenbringen kleinere
projekte broschüren workshops
konferenzen wandel durch annäherung ja
ich weiss es würdet ihr wahrscheinlich
auch für unrealistisch halten aber es
gibt überhaupt nicht die debatte darüber
es gibt nicht mal ansätze darüber und
deswegen glaube ich dass diese kritik
viele die die wenigen progressiven
fortschrittlichen kreativen kräfte in
katar die es gibt weniger als in
russland weniger als in brasilien viel
weniger aber das wird er dazu dass man
die wenigen noch weiter von sich
wegschiebt huby und co sage ich mal für
die ist jetzt einfach eine rote linie
erreichen gab jetzt verschiedene
beispiele von menschenrechtsverletzungen
von von autokratischen strukturen usw
von königshäusern die offenbar nicht
wandelbar sein wollen so ist zumindest
die aussage gewesen kurze frage an euch
was glaubt ihr gibt es eine rote linie
kann man sport und politik trennen wo
wäre für euch eine rote linie schreibt
uns gerne in die kommentare und jetzt
darf nennen noch mal sprechen weil du
bist ja auch schon länger nicht zu wort
gekommen lasst uns doch mal über
realistische möglichkeiten vielleicht
reden für wie realistisch hältst du es
denn dass ein mitte zwanzig jahre nehmen
wir das war komisch
warum denn jetzt gerade
kein anderes beispiel wer würde sich
hinstellen und sagen ich fahre nicht mit
ist das denkbar ist dass überhaupt
denkbar traut man sich das als aktiver
profi
sind sehr schwierige schurig hätte sehr
viel respekt für ihn wenn er das tut die
tatsache ist ich habe jetzt eine
stiftung seit knapp zehn jahren im
fußballgeschäft muss ich jedes mal durch
eine neue hürde durch allein weil ich
mich irgendwie politisch äußert oder
weil ich noch neben meinem
professionellen fußball beruf noch nicht
professionell mit gemeinwesen
auseinandersetzen das heißt würde die
würde es immer wenn etwas schief läuft
ist es weil ich etwas anderes noch mache
also wenn ich einen fehler mache wird
der auf die stiftung zurückgeführt
werden wenn ein anderer spieler genau
den gleichen fehler macht mir ein
normaler mensch licht also man hat
irgendwas wo man sagen kann weißt du was
wir zahlen ja dann bist du fußballspiels
und in anführungsstrichen auch die
fresse hältst du das ja und wenn du
kritisierst dann gerne irgendwie
mit irgendeiner symbol gestik die nichts
kostet und auch wahrscheinlich nichts
bewirkt sondern eigentlich genau das
falsche signal an die gesellschaft ist
okay aber du hältst es für relativ
unwahrscheinlich dass sich ein aktiver
profi irgendwie aus protest in die
öffentlichkeit stellten sagt ich fahre
nicht mit zur wm richtig habe ich
richtig finde dass das liegt wiederum am
system an druck das liegt an den
interessen und am druck es ist eine
power dynamik in der die vereine vor
allem entscheiden und wahrscheinlich
wenn jemand sich dagegen entscheiden
würde was nicht nur schlecht für die
person in der nationalmannschaft sondern
wahrscheinlich würden die vereine oder
der verein bei dem der jeweilige spieler
auch da ist sehr schnell eine konsequenz
daraus ziehen gibt einige symbolische
aktion jetzt also die sie regenbogen
aktionen ist also der fußball ist so
politisch wie nie zuvor wir sollten uns
dafür kritisieren dass wir den fußball
markt so haben wachsen lassen dass
jemand wie katar in erscheinung tritt da
kann man die fifa kritisieren da kann
man die großen globalen fußball marken
bayern münchen barcelona real madrid
kritisieren die wir mit unseren trikot
kaufen unseren pay tv abos groß gemacht
haben aber daran liegt bei uns auch eine
große schuld weil wir diesen markt eben
auch füttern mit unserem interesse wird
unsere nachfragen aber du hast uns
deswegen sollten wir da jetzt also ganz
normal die wm spielen und ich war ja die
menschenrechte werden verletzt das war's
da kannst du kannst deinen verein dein
club könnte das beispiel boykottieren
weil der ein teil des systems ist du
könntest mein trikot nicht kaufen du
könntest vielleicht kommt regus weil
gazprom draufsteht da ist genau das ist
mal ein guter schritt da könntest du
deine freunde du könntest eine deiner
deine deine abgeordneten im wahlkreis
für das thema interessieren du könntest
offenen brief schreiben du könntest eine
kampagne starten du bist ein
überdurchschnittlich engagierte verein
das weiß ich aber wir müssen uns vor
augen führen wir sind eine kritische
minderheit und die fußball blase platzt
auch nicht da werden millionen und
abermillionen menschen wieder diese wm
schauen weil fernseher weil
nachrichtenportale weil sponsoren weil
alle davon profitieren
und deswegen haben wir eine macht als
haben wir als konsumenten eine macht die
wir noch zu erreichen nutzen so benjamin
jetzt gab es hier so viele vorschläge
abgeordnete keine trikots kaufen mehr
dialog wandel durch annäherung du bist
trotzdem noch keinen schritt nach vorne
gegangen was muss denn passieren damit
überzeugt ist ich würde mir wünschen
dass
die katarische regierung
konsequent diese gesetze die dazu da
sind menschen zu schützen die arbeits
rechte zu schützen das die konsequent
durchgesetzt werden dass unternehmen die
dagegen verstossen bestraft werden das
ist aus meiner sicht die kraft und die
power die diese regierung hat ein
zeichen was sie setzen könnten da geht
es nicht um annäherung oder dass fußball
system zu ändern oder sonst irgendwas da
geht es um eine klare strategie um eine
handlung und das hat leider in den
letzten zehn jahren nicht stattgefunden
und solange das nicht stattfindet
bleibe ich hier stehen okay lass uns
doch jetzt in einer art kompromiss runde
rein gehen dass wir am ende noch mal
ganz kurz versuchen noch mehr menschen
irgendwie mehr in die mitte zu kriegen
ich mache ein vorschlag danach macht
jeder gruppe von euch
einen vorschlag und dann schauen wir mal
ob wir noch weiter auseinandergehen oder
vielleicht doch ein bisschen mehr
zusammenkommen mein vorstand ist einer
darüber haben wir noch gar nicht so viel
geredet welche rolle nämlich finden wir
sport und politik denken welche rolle
die politik spielen könnte jetzt ist ja
auch gerade china und olympia in der
debatte da gibt es einige staaten die
sagen aus protest schicken wir nicht
unsere großen minister oder staatschefs
dahin sondern wir schicken wenn
überhaupt nur kleinere diplomaten und
ich dachte mir das können wir doch für
katar vielleicht auch machen das heißt
also sagen wir so nie einen kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner erst mal könnt er der
forderung zustimmen die würde doch auch
in die bundesregierung gehen ja wir
stecken die nationalelf hin aber nein
wir schicken nicht den neuen
bundeskanzler hin also wie radeln das
ganze nicht in dem wir am ende olaf
scholz zusammen mit dem könig im stadion
sitzen haben sondern sagen öffentliche
repräsentanten gehen nicht dahin aber
die nationalelf schon wenn er sagt das
kann ich mir vorher sind ganz guter
vorschlag x mal anders gedacht
nationalelf jahr aber regierung nicht
dann könnte der schritt nach vorne gehen
und wenn ihr sagt mir reicht mir nicht
dann bleibt er stehen oder geht nach
hinten
drei leute warum warum findest du nicht
gut ja weil wer wenn ich ein
hochrangiger politiker kandhamal sagen
leute ihr mit euren arbeitsrechten und
so weiter also bitte jetzt reicht's aber
auch mal also da kann man ja mal
informell auf der tribüne oder was weiß
ich nachher nochmal sprechen weil wenn
da so ein kleiner diplomaten johnny
ankommt den nimmt ja keine auf deiner
seite versuche ich dich anzunehmen und
ein klares zeichen zu setzen also wenn
der bundeskanzler nicht zum wm-endspiel
fährt deutschland gegen england und der
bundeskanzler sagt mir ich komme aber
nicht das wäre schlecht wenn der
bundeskanzler hinfährt und quasi gute
miene zum bösen spiel macht und sich
darauf ihren lässt und sagt alles super
dafür sollte er dann nicht hinfahren
dann sollte er besser seine haltung
zeigen und der ganzen veranstaltung
fernbleiben wenn er aber sich vornimmt
da endlich mal auf den tisch zu hauen in
anführungsstrichen oder den finger in
die wunde zu legen und ein bisschen die
den druck aufrechtzuerhalten
dann ist das ja dann dort die chance
aber es geht ja um kompromisse und
deswegen finde ich das ist ein es ist
ein guter kompromiss wir haben fast
jetzt schon rollen getauscht das ist
eigentlich auch meine haltung trotzdem
würde ich von dieser haltung ein
bisschen abdrücken und es macht nur sinn
wenn du das olaf scholz oder andere
regierungsmitglieder dort nicht hin
reisen wenn sie auch darüber hinaus den
kritischeren ton anschlagen sie müssen
das unterfüttern wenn es aber immer
wieder wenn wenn wenn wenn mal wieder
der große autobauer bisschen geld
braucht oder die eine deutsche bank oder
sonst und wenn die aufmerksamkeit weg
ist dann wird so weitergehen dann glaube
ich nicht so richtig findet aber
trotzdem es ist ein für alle seiten
gesichtswahrende alle seiten
gesichtswahrende kommt muss wirklich
sagen so ich würde euch jetzt bitten
merkt euch eure position steckt man
wissen die köpfe corona gerecht zusammen
und überlegt euch irgendeine these einen
satz den wir gleich vortragen könnte
dazu
[Musik]
das ist mit sicherheit wenn wir einen
vorschlag bringen können aber es ist
jetzt konkret es ist aber es ist genauso
wie sie zwischen nationalmannschaft die
gruppen sind also gerade in der
kompromissfindung was wäre denn euer
vorschlag welcher kompromisslinie würdet
ihr zeichnet also wie kriegen wir diese
beiden gruppen noch enger zusammen in
der frage boykott ja oder nein gibt es
ein mittelweg schreiben sie mir gerne in
die kommentare
und das ist ja das problem dass wir mal
denken bis zur wm und ein jahr danach
sei alles wieder hängen
dabei habt ihr irgendwas solche überlegt
fangen wir haben uns überlegt das sinn
machen würde wenn wir ganz ganz viele
unterschiedliche akteure zu einem dialog
zusammen bringen und zwar aus katar aus
europa auch aus den entsende staaten der
migranten aus bangladesch und anderen um
zum beispiel ein drei länder turnier
durchzuführen das ganze zu begleiten mit
veranstaltungen mit diskussionsforen um
über diese probleme der migration
aufmerksam zu machen weil das ist kein
problem dass demokratie betrifft soll es
ein problem was die gesamte welt nach
kart habe treffen wird und hier einfach
diese diese austausch zu schaffen damit
am ende auch menschenrecht und
arbeitsschutzrecht eine benchmark werden
auch für länder wie katar damit sie
darum einfach nicht mehr drum herum
kommen bei der druck so groß ist dass
sie sonst eben hinten runter fallen
würden in der öffentlichen
berichterstattung glauben wir dass eine
solche veranstaltung oder mehrere
veranstaltungen die eben
unterschiedliche gruppen zusammenbringen
hier sehr gut helfen könnte stimmte dem
zug geht den schritt nach vorne dann
dürft ihr das jetzt tun und wenn ihr
zweifel habt könnt ihr sie gerne
begründen also ist eine super sache als
hans im fuß gut vorgetragen
[Gelächter]
top-spiele feinde machen wie dialog ist
ja auf jeden fall
wichtig und anlassbezogen das zu machen
ist natürlich was das hat mit der wm
jetzt erstmal gar nichts mehr zu tun
sondern man macht extra nochmal angebot
dazu deswegen finde ich das gut weil es
konkret ist inwiefern man da die leute
wirklich dazu kriegt also zu kommen oder
sich auch kritische sachen anzuhören
jetzt von katholischer seite oder von
denen die von diesen machtstrukturen
profitieren das lasse ich mal
dahingestellt aber so zwecks aufklärung
und nicht nur schwarz weiß der weg ist
jetzt ein bisschen schlauer sachen
gleich sind der sache ist ja dass alle
akteure mit da reinkommen und sich
engagieren und das ist auch jetzt
vielleicht nach der wm erstmal
stattfinden würde war es sehr wichtig
ist genau dass wir nicht zu dem punkt
kommt der mist vorbei nächste em nächste
wm und die aufmerksamkeit des komplett
weg sondern auch tatsächlich kommen ja
was es danach noch realisiert und da
sozusagen am ball bleiben um eben nicht
immer dazu stehen zu sagen das ist alles
doof da mit dem system und den ländern
aber wir gucken trotzdem also genau ein
bisschen ins heim hinzu kommen okay das
war der vorschlag habt ihr auch ein
vorschlag unsere vorstellung ist
eigentlich ein ganz konkretes beispiel
also es gibt schon es gibt schon etwas
nämlich der dänische fußballverband hat
sich dazu durchgerungen das
keine sponsoren tafeln während dieser
weltmeisterschaft im trainingslager im
hotel zu sehen sein werden sondern
stattdessen botschaften pro
menschenrechte mit zustimmung der
sponsoren das heißt also die verzichten
auf geld verzichten auf diese große
bühne ja das größte sportereignis was es
gibt und dort gibt es ein konkretes
beispiel was ich finde was alle verbände
übernehmen sollten ihr seid alle nach
vorne gegangen ist und das kann ich nur
begrüßen absolut ich bin nicht für mehr
sponsoren und noch mehr geht so ein
statement ich kann mir auch positiv also
das finde ich es mal so wenn eine
zeitgemäße gesellschaftspolitik um
fußball schließt sponsoren ein indem sie
weg bleiben können sie damit sogar geld
verdienen indem sie ihr image weiterhin
schärfen und profil gewinnen und das
finde ich aber legitim weil das ist eine
kommerzielle kommerzialisierte branche
sind wirtschaftszweig und ich finde die
klubs sollten noch mehr auf progressive
sponsoren unternehmen zugehen die
vielleicht mit solchen menschenrechts
botschaften dann auch zielgruppen und
eben noch mehr geld verdienen deswegen
dass dänemark finish ja gutes beispiel
ja ich wollte nur noch mal kritisch da
ergänzen dass das ja auch die gefahr
aber birgt das so unternehmen sich
reinwaschen also bei
black metal haben wir gesehen dass ja
auch das als als als marketing und als
werbetool dann benutzt wird also dass
politik schnell zur werbung wird weil es
halt gerade vogue ist und ich war nicht
so hundertprozentig überzeugt also gute
idee ja da kann man machen ich war dann
nicht so ganz überzeugt von diesem so
der aufschlag war ich mir denke es ist
genauso wie diese fifa und uefa die
überall hängen da steht ja ein guter
spruch und am ende aber vielleicht noch
einen satz wo ich meine kombiniert mit
dem vorschlag den wir gemacht haben wäre
das ja tatsächlich ein ansatz wo man
beides zusammenbringen könnte weil dann
auch man man auch dann der gefahr im
gegen beugen würde dass es eben und
reines marketing ist und von daher
glaube ich ist er vielleicht die
kombination aus den beiden was hier
gemacht haben ein ansatz ich fand es
sehr bereichernd weil wir einerseits auf
und so gut inhaltlich ausgetauscht haben
paar neue perspektiven da reingekommen
sind auch zueinander gekommen sind aber
dann auch wieder uns entfernt haben
insgesamt sehr dynamisch und soll bis
mir auch oft die fans also ich fand das
auch sehr wertschätzend ich habe mich
auch über eine perspektive wieder eine
sehr gefreut weil die natürlich sehr
exklusiv auch ist also keiner von uns
hat die erfahrung selbst als spieler da
auch vielleicht in die rolle
reinzukommen entscheidung zu treffen und
deswegen bin ich sehr dankbar dass so
mich da auch persönlich bereichert hast
ja ich habe schon noch die hoffnung dass
vielleicht ein einzelner spieler oder
wichtiger funktionär oder ein ehemaliger
was weiß ich david beckham zinédine
zidan
in der größenordnung dass die sagen ich
fahre da nicht hin und ich gucke mir das
nicht an und ich rede aber darüber und
trete in formaten auf dicke sich
kritisch mit katar auseinandersetzen
also dass man schon nicht glauben muss
dass boykott und fehlende aufmerksamkeit
gleich sind sondern kann sich ergänzen
würde ich zustimmen ich finde schade
dass sowie diskutiert haben ja kritisch
trotzdem gleich wertschätzen das hätten
wir viel früher machen sollen also die
wm wurde vor elf jahren vergeben ist
sehr sehr lange her und das narrativ ist
gesetzt und es wäre schön gewesen wenn
wir früher auf die idee gekommen wären
also wir haben gesehen wenn man
kompromisse sucht oder
lösungsvorschlägen sucht kann man auch
welche finden ihr seid alle relativ nahe
zusammengekommen ich habe das gefühl
wenn man diese ganzen vorschläge jetzt
kombiniert dann würdet ihr vielleicht
sogar noch weiter im inneren feld stehen
aber ich möchte jetzt nicht hinbringen
ja liebe politik lieber dfb liebe
sponsoren wir haben hier ein paar
vorschläge gemacht bitte achtet sehr
darauf wie ihr mit euren
regierungsvertreter ihnen umgeht in
katar bitte nehmt diese diesen vorschlag
ernst gründet ein netzwerk mit allen
zusammen um eben einen nachhaltigen
dialog über die wm hinaus zu etablieren
und vielleicht liebe sponsoren und
lieber dfb könnt ihr euch bei den dänen
tatsächlich ein beispiel nehmen vw grüße
hier liegt einiges auf dem tisch wir
haben den eindruck dass könnte eventuell
weiterhelfen und die nächste folge heißt
dann fifa zerschlagen ja oder nein
in diesem sinne ganz herzlichen dank
vollkommen klar alle beteiligten heute
sind natürlich gegen
menschenrechtsverletzungen die große
frage wird sein wie gehen wir am besten
gegen sie vor und ich glaube ein
weiteres thema ist heute auch noch
deutlich geworden nämlich dass der profi
fußball an sich mal auf den prüfstand
gestellt werden sollte das betrifft auch
den dfb und vor allem die fifa wenn ihr
13 fragen nicht so schlecht findet dann
abonniert doch einfach unseren kanal das
könnt ihr hier tun und eine weitere
folge 13 fragen findet ihr hier oben und
hier gibt es ein weiteres video zum
thema